los datos italianos son más bien graves
solo ahora sin la comisión de
investigación los datos que nosotros
hemos recolectado sobre el territorio
italiano son los siguientes frecuentes
actualmente en italia décadas de
existente cuando tenemos 164 sacerdotes
actualmente investigados que no han
alcanzado el tercer grado de juicio
mientras que tenemos 162 que si han
alcanzado el tercer grado de juicio por
lo tanto han sido condenados y tienen
sentencia firme o esto
en definitiva tenemos 30 obispos con
casos conocidos
161 nuevos señalamientos y 471 casos
impunes es decir casos que nunca
llegaron ante la justicia civil por
estar prescritos y ni siquiera llegaron
a la iglesia debido a que las víctimas
no tienen confianza en la iglesia o en
las instancias para denunciar los de la
justicia civil en cuanto prescrito y no
formalmente malla debate la banquera el
potencial de víctimas que hemos
calculado en italia sobre la base de las
comisiones de investigación de los datos
recolectados en todo el mundo supera el
millón de víctimas de la víctima que
habíamos calculado en italia sub la base
de la comisión en ingesta de edad que
mercé indulto el mundo es figura y la
millones de víctimas